-It's nice having you
in New York.
You guys took advantage
of being in New York.
You threw out the first pitc
last night...
-I did.
-...at the Mets game.
-I did. I'm very athletic.
-Yes, everybody knows that
-Yes, exactly.
Uh, no.
I was always picked last
in gym class.
So when this sort of e-mai
came through, I was like -
immediately, "Yes,"
as a child.
The 8-year-old me was like
"Absolutely want to do this.
Followed by terror,
because I know
what it's like being picked last
in gym class.
I was, like "There's tens of
thousands of people there.
-How much time did you hav
between getting asked
and doing the actual pitch
-Three weeks.
And I hired a pitching coach
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Because I'm that kind of nerd
-Yeah.
-And a really nice guy
named Zach in L.A.,
who, like, showed me
how to throw a baseball.
-I would imagine one of th
problems would be overthrowing
over the course
of the three weeks.
You don't want to end up
with, like, a sore arm.
-No, no, and there are
plenty of celebrity videos
of people who have thrown badly,
which is, like, the nightmare.
-And lot of them in New York
-Yeah, no, I know.
And the coach says to me,
in the third training sessio
we had, he's like,
"You know what?
Your body is not gonna perform
the way a pitcher
needs to perform."
[ Laughter ]
It's like, "Sweet.
I'm glad you're telling me thi
in my third session."
He goes, "Why don't you
just perform
as though you're confident?"
-Oh!
-It's like, "Oh, thanks.
Now, it's acting-lesson time."
-So, he said,
"You can't be a pitcher,
but you can be an actor
playing a pitcher."
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-We're going to show it.
Before we show it,
how do you feel you did?
-So, I did an Insta story
where I sort of bragged
about throwing strikes.
In reality, it's
a little high and outside.
-Okay.
-But it went across the plate,
he didn't have to chase it
and it didn't hit the ground
-Alright, let's take a loo
real quick,
and let's see if you
would call this a strike.
-Ha!
-And... [ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
He had a -- You had a very..
[ Applause ]
I like that whoever
was catching for you
did that very nice thing.
He didn't panic.
He just very calmly stood up
-Yeah.
-It was like,
"I was getting up anyway."
-Exactly, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
And I was, like --
And in my head I'm like,
"The actor can
talk a mean game,"
but clearly the pitch was
what it was, guys.
-So, "Sunnyside."
This is a show
you've had an idea for,
for a long time.
You created it with Matt Murray,
who's a wonderful writer
who used to be
my officemate at "SNL."
And you play, from the clip,
a disgraced councilman
who is now helping immigrant
pass their citizenship test.
-Yeah, yeah.
Five years ago,
I was on a show
that got abruptly canceled
and kind of thought, "Well
what's your dream project?
And I love making people laugh
I love the patriotic comedie
that we grew up with --
stuff like -- I know
it doesn't sound patriotic
but, like "Fresh Prince"
and "Seinfield."
Basically, stuff
that makes you feel good
at the end of the night,
you know?
You feel like you just hung ou
with a group of your friends
So we thought, "A teacher
is kind of a cool idea.
Maybe it's, like,
maybe teaching,
like, a chocolate-making class
It went through all these
different iterations
until we sat down
with Matt and Mike Schur
and thought, "A citizenshi
class is kind of cool --
one that takes place
in New York City,
because there's a lot
to choose from.
And the sort of hijinx,
each episode, is a nice runner
-It's also, you know,
a very diverse cast,
as sort of the plot
would necessitate.
And everybody has very
interesting backgrounds,
which is a really cool
part of it.
You recently got to do -- an
I did this season, as well -
Henry Louis Gates.
-Oh, "Finding Your Roots"?
-"Finding Your Roots."
-Okay.
I did do "Finding Your Roots
recently.
-Yeah.
-And I said yes to it
because they hire
these fancy genealogists
and then do a DNA test, an
I've always thought it was coo
that when you watch
those commercials,
someone's like, "I found out
that I was like
a half Scottish."
-Yeah.
-And, like, I've always been
super jealous
of people with, like,
their coat-of-arms tattoos
-Sure.
-I've always wanted a tattoo
So I'm like, "Alright,
I'm going to do this show.
I'm going to give them my DNA,
and I'm going to get a tattoo.
-Really?
-Yes.
-So, it was basically,
whatever they find out.
-Whatever they find out,
there will be something,
because it's permanent
and it's real,
and I know it's based on
DNA and history.
And so I did it, and
we're going through the book
and they go, "Turn the page no
for your DNA mapping."
And I turn the page and it says,
"You are 99.99% South Asian.
[ Laughter ]
And I was like,
"Oh, my gosh!"
And he goes,
"How do you feel, Kal?"
I'm like, "I feel disappointed."
It just came out of my mouth
[ Laughter ]
So, he turns the page agai
and he goes, "
This is called a haplogroup.
And it was this number "R1a"
that, in fact, I got the tattoo.
So I'll show you.
-Okay.
[ Crowd cheers ]
Wow. Wow.
[ Laughter ]
See? Throw out a first pitch
"R1a-M147."
-So that's your haplogroup
-That's my haplogroup.
There's a map.
It goes from Africa,
like, through the Caucasus
into India and South Asia.
And I then asked for more DNA.
They wouldn't give in to me.
They're like, "No, that's
our intellectual property.
I was like "No, guys.
R1a-M147.
I want to know
what else is there."
So then I was like,
"I can just buy a kit myself."
-Sure.
-It was 300 bucks.
I waited for the holidays,
when it was on sale for $99.
-Yep.
[ Laughter ]
-And then bought it.
Did the same thing.
I'm on the computer.
I'm like, "Alright, haplogroup."
I click on it.
"R1a-M417."
And I was like, "Wait a second
The tattoo I got is R1a-M147
Why is the computer telling me
that my haplogroup is M417?"
And I realize there has been
a phenomenal error.
[ Laughter ]
This is not my haplogroup.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-And did you get confirmation?
-I got confirmation.
I e-mailed them.
I e-mailed them and I said -
I said, "What's the deal, guys?"
They e-mailed back.
-You e-mailed PBS, basically
-I e-mailed the producers.
And two days later,
like 18 executives e-mail me
and say, "We're so sorry.
A P.A. swapped two of the digits
when they were
putting the screen up.
But, by the way, don't worry
We'll correct it
in post-production."
And I sent them a picture of
this tattoo, and I was like...
[ Laughter ]
..."You gonna correct this, too,
guys?"
Come on.
-You gonna CGI out my tattoo
-Yeah. They said they'd pa
for fixing it,
but I figured this was
a better story
to tell on a late-night show
one day.
-Absolutely.
Thank you very much
to Henry Louis Gates
for the story.
-Thanks, man.
-Kal Penn everybody!